fifteen what 16 they complete the
question sighs please keep reminding
please little s little I opt that's our
hash case insensitive huh insensitive
Twitter is case insensitive good you
know what a high-tech lorries are you
doing it live decide will go online and
the video giggling okay I need to decide
what to say now so for the weighted case
you can also use semi definite
programming you can actually optimize
optimize over this in polynomial time
that this is the stable set polytope so
the question was does this apply to the
weighted case so yes it applies to the
way the case because this is equal to
this table set polytope and so you can
use the machinery of SDP let me mention
a few things so you might you might
wonder okay fine if you optimize organs
is you get the value of the largest
table set or you get the value of the
largest weighted statement set but how
do you recover on the stable set because
you might not even though even though
stab is equal to th of G you might be
using an interim point I'll go in and
get a point inside the optimum phase and
the optimum phase
it's only the extreme points that are
Von Teese
so now two two easy answers to that
question so one of them is that you can
you can use basic some some
communitarian
way of doing it because what you could
say is that you could take a vertex V
and then compute alpha of the entire
graph and alpha of the entire graph -
Advantix assuming it's perfect yes
assuming it's perfect so if so if it is
not perfect the the optimizing over on
th of G will only give you a something
that's feasible him it's not necessarily
going to be in this in stable set
pollito and it will be difficult to
actually round this to a stable set so
so I'm not going to talk about this yes
yeah because remember the definition of
a perfect graph was in terms of all the
sub graphs so if it is if a graph is
perfect this graph is also perfect and
so you know that this is going to be
equal to theta of G minus V and this is
equal to theta of G and so you just have
to check if this is equal to one on to
the value of the vertex if it is you
know that it's part of the maximum
stable set and you can repeat so that's
one approach to do it another one it's
actually and I'd like to discuss that so
I'm going to do on this side so we'll
switch this for maybe ten minutes and
then I get back to it but you could also
ask so I have a I have these this
polygem set or I have these convex set I
mean this case in the case of tanta
graph they don't equal but suppose I
give you a vertex and on other contexts
I give you X in P and but you'd like to
decompose it in
- into elements of in s so for example
in all case you know that step of GE
from perfect graph is equal to th of G
and and so that's a continuous pace I
give you an X in that space but now
you'd like to express it in terms of the
stable sets which are only the Von Teese
so how do you do that
that's that's very simple way it's just
you can use you can always so I'm not
doing it in the case of stab but just in
general so I give you a point X in P and
I'd like to to decompose it into a
convex combination of elements of a set
as such that convex set of that is equal
to P so let's take a specific I mean
just illustrate it so for example if I
take let's take a 3d thing
let's take suppose I take the table on
graph and I take and I'd like to
decompose X and so one thing I could do
is first I'm going to look at the
smallest phase F containing X
and so it might be this face and then
within that face I'll go in any
direction and the opposite direction and
then I'm going to do a line so much so
that I'd like to hit the boundary of
that convex set on polytope or poly
agent and depending in what situation I
am in and then I will just express X as
so I've found my direction G such that X
plus D this is within the face and then
what I do is I just express it in terms
of X 1 and X 2 and X 2 so I I write X as
let's say lambda X 1 plus 1 minus lambda
X 2 and this is just X plus epsilon
epsilon 1 G and this is just X minus
epsilon 2 D that's it and then I just
know I'm in a small on dimensional
five-hitter smaller dimensional face and
now I repeat within that face I will
decompose that point into convex
combination of points in a smaller
dimensional face and I repeat eventually
I get to the wrong system
so that's provided I can make for
example these finding that D algorithmic
and provided I can do the line so much
algorithmically then I can decompose X
in the convex so so so for example in
this case what I could do you give me an
X what I could do is I could find a
faster Y satisfying this and then what I
would do is I would compute the face
what is the face well the face is going
to be I I will have to look at the eigen
values of Y so a face
so in the case of in the case so if I
want to remain so if you give me a why
that's positive semi-definite and I want
to go find a matrix let's call it Z such
that y plus Z's is still positive
semi-definite but it's in the face so
the phase will be given by the set of X
in in the Duomo such that x times y is
equal to zero so you you will need to
look at the you need to look at the
eigen values of Y and the eigen vectors
corresponding to the zero eigen value
and that will give you in that space you
can find any you can you can look at any
positive semi definite matrix whose
whose column is in that space so that
gives you so you would then be able to
to do this decomposition every time you
go to a smaller dimensional phase you
maintain the the vectors that are
orthogonal to Y or Y and you continue
yes you well right now it's not
efficient because you get two to the end
exactly so that's completely true that's
not efficient so instead what you want
to do is you want to do an algorithmic
version of carathéodory's theorem
so typically how you would do you take
your P which is the convex hull of s on
let's take the let me take the table on
graph so that it's in 3d and now I'd
like to decompose this point so instead
of one side of my face F instead what I
do is I take a vertex of that face so I
take V a vertex V in the face and then I
do a line so much along along the line
between V and X and so that will express
that will give me that will allow me to
express X in terms of that vertex plus
another vertex X 1 which is in a lower
dimensional phase and I can repeat so
that's
if I have a set of points s which is in
RN and I look at P which is the convex
hull of s for any X in P there exists
you can express X as a convex
combination
X is a convex combination of the
elements X is a convex combination of
these things and in addition the support
is small the support of lambda so the
number of non-zeros is at most D plus n
plus 1 one dimension n so and so this a
great McGowen shows shows his statement
now one one thing that's very useful in
in this statement is that in in this
result is that when you take actually
let me go back we go back to this one
from a second is that that question came
a bit a bit to only so otherwise what I
want to add a small small detail here is
that when you choose your direction
within the face it's actually you can
look at directions which corresponds to
so in the case of in the case for
example of polyhedra you can take your
direction to be parallel to one of the
edges of the so two you can take a
direction which is parallel to one of
the smallest non-empty non non trivial
faces in your poly tope so you can take
D to be to be parallel to an edge of P
so so this is quite useful in some
applications
yeah the support would still be launched
yeah the support will still be launched
that's true but when one of the nice
thing is that for example if I take just
wanted to mention this as an example
suppose you take a Metroid polytope and
I guess tomorrow I may want to define
these precisely
let me quickly define what may treat
polytope it maybe not giving too much
much detail so in a metropolitan in a
for Metroid
you have a ground set E and then you
have a collection of let's say bases or
independent sets let's independent sets
of of Yi so these are subsets of
elements of the ground set and these
independent sets and such that if if a
set is independent and J is a subset of
I then G is also independent and then
the the other key property is that if if
you have two sets that are independent
and one is bigger than the autumn then
there exists an element in the bigger
one not in the smaller one that such
that you can add that to the smaller one
and still be independent so for example
classic examples of matrix for example I
take a matrix over on some field and I
look at the columns of of that matrix
and I say that my ground set is the set
of columns and I say that a subset
of columns is independent if it is
linear linearly independent or on that
field so the classical notion and you
can see that that is satisfied
another example is for example if you
look at the forests in a graph so if I
look at so this is known as the graphic
Metroid if you take a graph and then you
look at a set of edges of that graph
that has no cycle so that's a forest
that you can check that this will
satisfy these two axioms and then the
the base is the basis of a matrix on
adjust the maximum independent subsets
so in the case in this example for
example the base would correspond to the
set of columns to the that correspond to
the so to the rank of the matrix so the
a maximum set of columns that are
linearly independent
in this case if the graph is connected
it would correspond to the spanning
trees in the graph now when you have a
matrix polytope one thing so for example
let's look at the basis so the basis so
that's let's denote them by so it's a
subset of I which corresponds to the
maximal independent sets and then I
could define I could define a polytope P
on that match of given that Metroid
which would be the set of X in in our II
which are the convex hull of all the
bases so I would define that as the
convex hull of the characteristic vector
of basis
the effect on our business
such that bees is a base and so the one
nice property of these Metroid is that
all all directions of that polytope are
very particular so all directions
correspond to just swapping two edges so
the directions of that polytope if I
look at the phase structure of that
polytope
I look at the faces of dimension 1 of
this poly tube will be will be direction
will be in the direction which
corresponds to one unit vector minus
another one so that's just a vector off
with just one one and one minus one and
so what's nice is you can always go in
the directions of the edges of the poly
tube if I give you any element of a
metroid poly tope what i can do is i can
always make changes that would i would
only go in a direction that changes to
coordinates at a time and namely it
increases one coordinate and it
decreases one coordinate and so for
example this is useful to prove the
following that in a metroid poly tope
if I take any point in a metric polytope
you can find a convex combination so you
can express X as a convex combination of
basis so that's lambda B times B being
the bases times the incident victim of
the bases such that if you view this
convex combination as a probability
distribution it's negatively correlated
and that has
so that has some nice applications so
what does that mean it means that if I
look at if I if I view this as a
probability distribution I can ask
what's the probability for example that
if I want to select a base B according
to this probability distribution I can
ask what's the probability that an
element is in is in basis and I can I
could check whether what happens if for
example I asked if two elements and the
bases or if I say I condition on another
element being the basis and so in the
case of negatively correlated
distribution this would be at most the
probability that in B so you can prove
this by just doing these steps along the
along the polytope and always taking an
edge always taking a direction of this
form so you can check that when you do
that you can by induction show that you
you you can express X as a convex
combination of so if you want going in
the in an edge parallel to in a
direction pointing to the thing you
could say that X is a convex combination
of these two and show that that
satisfies negative correlation so this
this technique was introduced by
I need some help Alvin dark
and there's someone right that was a
different day yeah okay so several
people in the audience so and and so
that allows to get a negative
correlation for any any metric polytope
and that that for example in the case of
the spanning tree pollito this was this
was one technique that we used in from
approximating the asymmetric travelling
salesman problem within a log n over log
log n in a paper by Azad poo and several
other people so there was a bit of a
tangential thing actually before I
switch back let me mention one more
thing that is not as well known but I
think it's it's a very nice result
extension of the
there's nothing to do with the topic of
my topic of my talk but I like to do
random walks and so that's a it's and
it's a it's a beautiful result if you if
you have seen I'll remind it to you if
you haven't seen it it's always great to
see so suppose suppose I give you a
bunch of convex sets so I give you know
so first I give you a bunch of set s 1 s
2 up to SN plus 1 in in N and suppose I
look at the convex hull of each of them
and suppose that I have an element in D
that belong to all of them so the for
example my could my first my s 1 could
be these three points that could be s 1
s 2 so one dimension to so I need to
give you three sets as two could be this
one and s 3 could be for example this
and so if I take the convex hull of all
of them I get this that one
and this one and indeed they have an
intersection and so so then what what
what this theorem says is that you can
actually find then and there exist
si in Si for every I such that X belongs
such that X belongs to the convex hull
of s 1 s 2 SN plus 1
I'm just the advantage of doing a
digression is that most people are
probably boned during my election so at
least so that they wake up maybe and see
something else so so for example in this
case I'm not exactly shown so for
example I could take maybe this one that
one and this one
and the convex I love that contains the
point and that's always true and it's
not true it's not true if I replace n
plus 1 by n so for example if I take
inlets in to space if I take these two
points and as this one and these two
points as two clearly the origin is in
the convex hull but if I take one point
from one and one point from the other
it's not satisfied then you can
generalize to any dimension now another
thing I'd like to say is that this is
not known to be these function as it is
is not known to be algorithmic so one
way one simple way that you can prove it
is that you could say well among all all
possible ways of doing it let me take
the S sub i's that minimize the distance
between X and that convex cell so
suppose that for example I have these
points that I get out of these but X is
not in it
so this could be s 1 and so on as J as
plus 1 and so I I select G so as to
minimize that distance if that distance
is 0 I'm done if it is not 0 then it's
easy to see that if I look at if if I if
I look at the closest point Z it's not
going to be in the Imperium of that
polytope of that simplex so it has to be
on one of the faces on one of the facets
and so since it's on the one of the
facets it means that there is at least
one J that's not on that face but so now
I can what I can do is I know how to
express Z as a convex combination of all
these sub i's except as J so now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to look
back at capital SJ and I know that
captain SJ has in its convex hull X so
it means that the must be an element of
capital SJ that's on this side of that
face and so I mean you have to I mean
it's a tiny bit fast but you can then
replace SJ by a new point as prime J
that's on that side of the face and so
that and when you do the calculations
you'll see that this gives you a set of
s 1 up to SN plus 1 such that so you
swapped one as J for another one such
that that means that distance decreases
strictly decreases and so it's not a
great make in the sense that it's not
known how long that takes
I will not repeat the question because I
don't know how to respond to the
question I'll take it offline okay so
that was a bit of a digression
let me maybe go back to go back to what
I had kind of prepared from the
collection so
good so could you turn the I think
so we are discussed so we weren't
talking about Cohen Cohen programming
and I had mentioned Cohen programming in
terms of duality but then we we so one
very nice example of the use of semi
definite programming from discrete
optimization problem let me show you
some other ones I'm especially
interesting so so there are quite a few
so the problem so in the case of the
theta body what was nice is that in the
case of profit graph that completely
describes the convex hull of Steve on
set but in general when you try to use
semi definite programming for discrete
optimization problems when you go from
when you have this map from the elements
of s to elements of P typically you get
young piece long-john than the convex
hull and so the question then is how you
get back from an element of P to an
element of s so in the case in which P
is equal to convex hull of s we know how
to do that I mean these algorithmic kind
of territory theorem for example gives
you back the convex combination so so
there are some many many nice examples
of the use of semi definite programming
in in community optimization one of them
is is an algorithm of David Williamson
and I for the maximum cut problem and a
the level circuit which is guaranteed to
be eight seven eight times the at least
eight seven eight times the optimum cut
later we we looked at a generalization
of the I mean a valiant of the problem
in which you try to separate the graph
not into two sets but into three sets
and you'd like to maximize the number
rages across the the cut and in that
case what we did was we we showed that
actually it's better not to use semi
definite programming but go one step
from the one go to complex as DP and and
that's the guarantee that we delivered
and that's a closed form expression very
nice of it and then we then also some
very nice use of semi definite
programming to approximate the sponsor
skirt problem and I will I would like to
start with this I'm not going to talk
about the maximum cut problem too many
people have probably seen it so I don't
want to discuss that I'd like to discuss
this and then hopefully I'll maybe
discuss a tiny bit these complex SDP as
well so what is the sponsor skirt
problem you are given a graph and you'd
like to partition into two sets so as to
minimize the ratio between the number of
edges across so that's what I was
calling Delta of s volume divided by the
total number of potential edges which is
as times the complement of s and so
that's an np-hard problem and it's it's
actually go at me clear as there's lots
of nice applications and so one thing
you could do is you could say well
instead of optimizing over so I could
what I could do remember every cut
I introduced that that victim which was
one on the cut so and and then I define
the cut cone to be the conic combination
of these things and so instead of I can
we formulate my so my sigh is minimizing
the value of the cut which is the sum
over the edges of one if it is in the
cut divided by the sum of all payments I
J of one if that's in the in the cut so
that's that sponsors cut so that counts
the number of edges in the cut that
counts the total possible number of
edges but then if you minimize over set
of victims ratio of linear functions you
could also say well I can instead of
optimizing over this I could optimize
over a vector Modi which is in the cone
so D is in the code generated by G's so
that would be the cut code and so on
problem is really to minimize over the
cut cone a linear function of them some
lynnium one lynnium constraint so that's
exactly so we have a nice cone and we
have this so we could if we could
understand the pole of this the dual of
this then we would have immediately a
way to attack the problem away from the
the the the record a large set of of a
large on set and then go back to the cat
code and the key idea was to view the
cuts as metrics so let me
so what is what do I mean by a metric I
mean simply that you have something
that's not negative symmetric and
satisfies the triangle inequality and
then you could look at so since this is
a ma genius
linear and homogeneous you can so this
defines a cone that's the metric code
and within that cone sits some of the
cuts because when I have a cut when I
look at one over Delta s that that's
really saying I have zero the distance
between any two point here 0 the
distance same thing here but across its
1 and that satisfies the triangle
inequality and so the cut cone is a sub
cone of the metric code nice thing about
the metric cone is that it's it's
finitely generated you would say so is
the the cut cone but the nice thing
about the metric cone is that we have
the inequality is defining it so it
means that when we go to the duo we have
the extreme ways of the metric cone
which we don't have for the cut corner
now one thing which is pretty easy to
see is that so any member of the cut
cone is a metric but the nice thing
about the cuts in the metric code in the
cut code is that they can be embedded
into l1 so what do I mean what do I mean
by that is that there exists a you can
find a map from from the volsces of yum
graph - let's say l1 in some let's say
in om some dimension M such that the
distance between x and y would be
precisely given by the one norm of of X
minus y and the reason why the cut cone
is the same thing as the l1 embeddable
the cone of l1 matrix is simply because
if you have an l1 metric so if I have an
L 1 metrics so if my points X 1 and so
on X 2 and so on in RM I can decompose
that metric easily into into a conic
combination of cuts because what I can
do is in every direction in every
dimension I can do a sweep and so for
example as I sweep let's say along this
coordinate axis I would just that would
define a cut a cut in which I have X 1
on one side and 2 & 3 on the other side
and on that cut I would put as the conic
coefficient on that cut just the the
that distance between so as I sweep so
it's it's very easy to a bit difficult
to write on the bone but when you do
that over from all dimension you'll see
that the distance the l1 distance
between x1 and x2 would be precisely the
amount that you put over on cuts
separating as x1 and x2 in this
direction in this direction and so on so
so the idea of linear London in Havilah
which was that instead of optimizing
over the CAD cone what you could do is
you could optimize over a long class of
metrics and then what you would try to
do is take that metric and map it back
to an l1 embeddable metric and when you
do that you would have to stretch some
of the distances so you would have to
modify some of these some of the
distances so in comes some distortion
and then you can decompose that into
cuts and
and so one one natural option would be
to take that luncheon class of matrix to
be just a metric on all all metrics and
so that's this is nice the welcome you
when you try to map any metric on
endpoints to a an l1 embeddable metric
some distance some edge will actually
get stretched by a factor of log in and
log any start in this sense that began
showed that for any metric on endpoints
it can always be embedded into l1 even
l2 which is a subspace of L 1 with a
distortion of log N and so and the nice
thing about the metric cone is that you
when you optimize override since you
have only linear inequalities that's
actually just linear linear programming
so you can optimize using linear
programming over the metric cone and
then you can map that metric so that's
the rounding step you can map that
metric back into l1 and then once you
have an l1 metric you can decompose it
into cuts and at least one of these cuts
will be within log n of the sponsors
sponsors cut and so that that's another
way of deriving a log n approximation
are green founds you to laitanan
I know what I did with a click on
actually so but then you can try to do
something so you have the you have the
cut cone the cut cone you have the so
this is the cut cone in any of these
metric cone and then him by optimizing
overseas and then moving it back to the
cut code you lose a factor of log n so
you may try to think about other types
of metrics that I'm between the cut and
the metric code so the nice one nice
class in fact I mean you if you want to
know anything about everything about
these about the cut cone and you should
look at you should look at the book by
DISA and aloha from the mid-90s that has
a ton of reasons about the cut Conan and
n properties of it so one one property
of any cut is these inequality so if I
take if if I have a graph and I assign
values to the Vinci so that the sum of
BI is equal to zero then if I look at
our graph if I look
if I look at the sum of bi BJ over the
IJ's in a cut this is going to be just
the sum of the bi or minus times the sum
of the BG or hanji nerdiness and so
that's going to be less than or equal to
zero if the sum is zero and so this is
true not just from a cut but it's going
to be true from anything in the cut cone
so that because that's and so you get
you get that that all the DS satisfying
these form a cone called a negative type
cone and that negative type code
contains the cut code so this condition
can be simply modified a bit you can see
that actually ad will satisfy all these
inequalities you can just eliminate one
of the B sub i's and then it would be
like a condition like from positive semi
definiteness and so the condition on
positive semi definiteness is that these
associated matrix after let's say
eliminating ends so that gives you these
values so that's the entry IJ of that
matrix that matrix has to be positive
semi definite that's equivalent to
asking that all these condition are
satisfied so and when you we interpret
that you can see that a metric will be
will be satisfying all these
inequalities if actually by taking the
square root of that metric so this may
not be a metric but if that's a metric
that's l2 embeddable then then the
metric is of negative type so so that
gives you Google gives you a geometric
interpretation of these of these
negative type
condition now the nice thing is that so
instead of optimizing over the metric
cone you could say I'd like a metric
that's also in G's negative type code so
to some you you intersect you take the
intersection of the metric code and
these negative type cone because this is
not the guarantee that X is actually a
metric so you you take the intersection
of these negative type cone and the
metric code and so then if you want to
use the machinery of convex programming
you could look at at the doom of that
cone and the dual of that cone is
actually can be nicely expressed so the
doom of the cone is the set of matrices
so so so I've used these distances as
matrices symmetric matrices with zero
diagonal because the distance from i to
i is zero and so the i'll see the dual
in the same way and one can show it's
not difficult to show that i mean from
what i said on the last slide is that
these the duo is going to be given by
the laplacian of the matrix y being
positive semi definite so so if you give
me an optimization problem which
involves the negative type cone the
metric cone and some linear constraints
i can I can write the dual and the dual
will involve the laplacian of so of the
variables in the door will involve also
metric inequalities because there will
be these metric constraints as well and
so I can optimize over this efficiently
now of course um it's it's not needed to
do all this because you don't need
negative type because you can remember
we said that
remember we said that
you could rewrite the negative type
condition in terms of semi definite
programming so you could rewrite that
optimization problem as a semi definite
program and by rewriting that that
program as a semi definite program you
can use just a machinery of semi
definite programming and so that's
that's what a whole how and buddy Ronnie
did and and in fact if you read you have
to push the result a bit from them to
Ave an embedding result but one can show
that these negative type metrics so all
metrics embed into l1 with distortion
logon but these negative type metrics
it's a more restricted class they embed
with this function essentially square
root of log N and very recently it was
shown that this is this is tied in in
the sense by now of annyeong we have
shown that some negative type metrics
required is a square root of n so this
give an integrated you get post buses
I can go home yes yeah yeah it does
and/or Indy in the uniform case or in
the general case so the way I define the
problem I simplified the problem so I
simplified the problem in the sense that
I assume that you know you have a it's
uniform so here the one between for
every IJ you have also another function
which is also called the sponsor skirt
the non uniform version in which you
have a demand and then you and so in in
the in the general in that demand case
yes it shows an integral T gap I mean
the thing is I mean first of all
integrality gap I'm not exactly sure I
mean I guess you mean the bridge the
worst-case ratio so no I don't think so
wait but also
right yeah so but not not of square root
log n so we don't have a tight one in
that case so it's it's Polly of log so
the consensus is that in the if you so
if you look at the ratio of the value
that you obtained by optimi optimizing
over all the the cuts and optimizing
organs is SDP obtained from negative
type that if you if you look at cases in
which there might be demands so of like
a duration of the problem I mentioned in
that case the gap can be square root log
N and the the class of instances that
that now when Jung looked at came from
metrics that arise from the isin group
Eisenberg group and but then if you look
at if if you look at uniform case as I
described then starting from result of
visionary you you get a non constant gap
so I think this was log log n to the one
sixth or something and then that was
pushed from them and now it's still
it's not route logging yeah that's the
easiest way to describe it
okay I have only three minutes left and
I I still prepared quite a few things
for today but but tomorrow I want to to
talk about a different topic so because
I realized that I haven't talked much
about min/max relations so I'd like to
change gears tomorrow but I'd like to
quickly mention like a take-home message
I was hoping to show so the from this
razón so so in the max three cut problem
what you'd like to do is you'd like to
partition the vertex set of a graph into
three sets and you'd like to maximize
the number of edges in between the sets
and you could try to use the you could
try to use the machinery of semi
definite programming to get a good
approximation out well then you can do
that it's possible to do a welcome it's
actually in this case it's much easier
to it's much easier to actually just
trying to find okay it's much easier to
do it open complexes DP and so in that
case what you would do is you would
assign each vertex instead of assigning
it to eat them the phone spawn the
second point on some part you would
assign it a victim that's one of the
three cubic roots of unity and and then
one could one can show that you can
obtain a relaxation you can you can view
that if y u and y v are one of the cube
roots of unity this crazy expression
would be either 1 or 0 depending on
whether the edge is in the cut or not
and so now you could try to
optimize overall such wise you would put
some constraints to try to to put the
wine in the convex I love these
and then what you would get is a is a
complex semi definite program so
essentially instead of optimizing over
just y being these three elements you
would optimize over y being in that set
that's the complex plane and then you
would get linear inequalities and that
would give you that that would give you
a complex as DP so the you would look at
the mission matrix that the gram matrix
corresponding to these victims and that
would be a complex matrix and then you
optimize all of this now the reason I
wanted to mention this is that complex
as DP is actually the same thing as we
own as DP there is an easy map so if if
actually if a matrix Z is supposed to be
PSD or from the the complex then if I if
I double the size of the matrix and
consider this matrix then it's going to
be passed PSD of all the wheels and so
any program like this can be can be
transformed into a wheel as DP a welcome
when you solve that program you so you
would get the same solution if you look
at it on the complex on him in that a
wave then you have to do the rounding
you have to go back from that even
complex SDP to cut a three cut from that
we own as DP to a 3k and I'll spare you
the analysis but after some tedious
analysis we realized that was much
easier to do it over the complex number
it was tedious or on the complex number
but not not so easy over the the real
and and we got some proven guarantee so
so the the take home message him is that
I mean there has been over the last few
decades there have been a lot of use of
SDP from discrete optimization problems
but sometimes one may want to go to do
something that even though might be
equivalent I mean it is equivalent
complex SDP but that might give you a
bit more mileage and in fact again I'm
going to go back to my to something I
said in the first hour you may even want
to go to a hyperbolic optimization which
might be even a step from them and this
might have some really cool applications
in discrete optimization and so you
might wonder what is hyperbolic
optimization so that motivates you to go
and study it or you can ask me or
especially Jim that's it for today so
tomorrow what I'm going to do is I'll
switch I'm going to switch gears
completely and I'll try to do few random
excursions and focus a bit more to what
been asked me to do
[Music]
difference between say yeah that's a I
mean the problem is that yeah it it
depends how you do the embedding from
the the path so then you would you would
like to let's say map one up to one two
three four to some space in which you
could decide if in which from these you
know products you could see if I is not
equal to J and knowing you seem to route
to lose more and more so as you do it
because you it's hard to say eyes and I
mean like the configure yeah
again
[Music]
we'll be a lunch